speaking of fumbling the bag it's not
really fumbling a bag but speaking of
blowing a bag to get your [ __ ]
daughter into college and then end up
doing prison time let's go our Laurie
lock Lori Loughlin yeah shout to Lori
Loughlin free her okay the system is
[ __ ] up watch her come out of this and
talk about how jails are so terrible oh
my god we got to make free Laurie shirts
dude how funny would that be oh you know
the irony is that she is you know she
got a charge for you know faking her
daughter's transcripts and now she's
basically just gonna do a semester of
college as a punishment she gonna sit in
a [ __ ] small cell and then go to the
library during rec hours and read books
and then go outside occasionally and
then be trappin her own thoughts for
eight weeks and then that said yeah
lesson that two months dude that's
nothing what's where she going
[ __ ] probably maximum security Club
fed she's gonna have a cell phone and a
Playstation and it's going to yeah she's
going to tennis prison yeah it's just
like giant tennis courts beautiful it's
just like summer camp bro she's probably
gonna the long beach prison dude that
[ __ ] isn't a cove on the water and no
way really yeah it's a resort location
dude it's unbelievable
that's funny and and who the the her
husband is doing five months why is her
husband doing five well you know the
disproportionate that's just you know
how like women make less on money yeah
you know it's just kind of like a
continuation to that when they do less
nice plus or prison sentences I see
[Laughter]
see there is benefit to gender
inequality yeah Jesus Christ for I am
joking I am joking I am joking free
lorry man free lorry the most offensive
shirt ever free Lori Loughlin I tweeted
that this morning for 10 seconds and
took it down just three - what that's
just - aided free Lori Loughlin all caps
and I had I deleted it just I had to get
it out of my system so [ __ ] funny yo
yo hey Lori man bring my girl man she
didn't do nothin they put in the sweet
innocent that [ __ ] gonna be listening
to the Box in the room Jesus can't wait
for her first day out that's a whack job
that's a whack job everyone saying that
[ __ ] hell man
wait goddammit Lori Loughlin is gonna
sit on that prison toilet and think wait
this isn't a bidet it's so small
Lee that's why Lori sell may just you
know farting up a storm at night just
you know stinky stinky it's a he or she
or she I mean this co-ed prison to that
exist no it doesn't exist right now I
feel like that has to exist there's code
do this co-ed dodgeball Illinois are
they here
Cora are there any co-ed federal prisons
in the United States
oh because I'm trying to go yeah can I
get transferred to that I have female
camps at the same location with a myth
okay they don't interact with each other
yeah okay
so anyways Laurie's female cellmate some
you know stinky ice-cream girl sippy
she's lactose
it made you lactose-intolerant you know
and they're serving ice cream one night
and she's as rip and stinkers and prison
lorry soon see that's funny parking
expand and Lilith and Laurie just can't
stand it she now regrets the top bunk
put me in isolation yeah I can't handle
this anymore crazy
I imagine that she's going to cry for
the first week becoming just depends on
where she goes to jail totally you know
I thought about I doubt she ends up in
some like real scary ass prison [ __ ] I
finally I I don't know who knows how
that [ __ ] works but yeah I guess when
you're rich can you just buy your way
into like a nice bougie little rehab
prison or does that not I don't know how
maybe like maybe your lawyer can make
file some motion to get you to you know
whatever or she you know she agrees to
serve the two months in prison and then
I bet she's there for a week and then
they get her out on an ankle monitor and
you know she has to live in her pool
house for seven weeks and then and then
she does a collaboration with 6:9 yeah
and they drop a single together oh that
Olivia Jade six nine video couldn't
happen faster in the pipeline brother
wait what I bet they're gonna capitalize
Lori Loughlin daughter and six nine bet
you they just do a little something
together yeah probably like an Instagram
live or something something yeah yeah
can you get my mom some tips and they're
gonna call that [ __ ] ratatouille
[Laughter]
you